In addition to the hardware crypto
capabilities built into each IOS device,
Apple uses a technology
called data protection
to further protect data stored
in flash memory on the device.
Data protection allows the device
to respond to common events.
Such as incoming phone calls but also
enables a high level of encryption for
user data.
Critical system apps such as messages,
mail, calendar, contacts,
photos and health data values
use data protection by default.
And third party apps install on iOS 7 or
later receive this
protection automatically.
Data protection is implemented
by constructing and
managing a hierarchy of keys.
And views on the hardware encryption
technologies going to each IOS device.
Data protection is controlled on
a profile basis by signing each
file a class.
And access to the file is determined
by whether the class keys have been
unlocked.
Each time a file is created,
data protection creates a new
256 bit profile key and
gives it to the hardware AS engine
which uses the key to encrypt a file
as it is written to flash memory and
the encryption is sent
through ASCBC mode.
The profile key is wrapped or encrypted
with one or several class keys.
And the wrapped per file key is
stored in the files metadata.
That is, the file key is used
to encrypt the file contents and
the key itself is encrypted using
the class key and the encrypted or
wrapped key is stored
in the files metadata.
The file metadata itself is
encrypted using a file system key.
Then when a file is opened or
accessed this metadata is encrypted
using the file system key.
This will reveal
the route to profile key
then the profile key is
unwrapped with the class key.
The profile key then can
be used to decrypt the file
as it is read from the flash memory.
The metadata of all
files in the file system
is encrypted using the same random key.
We call it the file system key.
This key is created when
iOS is first installed, or
when the device is wiped by the user.
The class key is protected
with the hardware UID, and for
some classes, with the user's passcode.